John Ritter was a sitcom Legend but his
final words to Kaley Cuoco didn't make
her laugh instead they left a mark on
her heart forever before Kaley Cuoco was
the outgoing neighbor Penny on The Big
Bang Theory or the foul-mouthed baseball
bat swinging anti-heroine in Harlequin
she was the bubbly eldest daughter on
eight simple rules Cuoco starred
alongside John Ritter Katie Seagal Amy
Davidson and Martin spangers in the
family-orientated sitcom eight simple
rules follows the Hennessy family as
Ritter's Paul faces The Perils and
hilarity of fatherhood the Lively comedy
balances portrayals of patronizing male
stereotypes with Ritter's multi-faceted
performance as the protective Paul
throughout the series Paul's patriarchal
instincts are checked and corrected with
his daughters portrayed as expressive
individuals rather than oppressed prizes
Poco was an exceptional vessel of this
thematic element during her time on the
series which she again channeled as
Penny in The Big Bang Theory in 2003
Ritter tragically died suddenly during
production of the beloved family sitcom
he was nominated posthumously by the
Emmys for his nuanced performance in
eight simple rules upon the 15th
anniversary of Ritter's death Cuoco
shared the special relationship she had
with her fatherly co-star their support
of closeness was evident in their
on-screen chemistry which made Ritter's
passing all the more devastating with
Entertainment Tonight she revealed the
lasting and emotional Last Words gifted
to her by Ritter when he isn't scaring
off boys or setting curfews Paul is
mentoring his young daughters with a
strong but loving hand John Ritter
continued this off screen by creating a
family atmosphere behind the scenes as
well as in front of the camera this gave
his untimely death even more weight as
he made his rounds to say goodbye to his
fellow cast members particularly his TB
daughter Kaylee Cuoco she iterated just
how much she loved Ritter by recalling
their final moment in a tearful and
extraordinary retelling with
Entertainment Tonight in her words after
hearing that he was sick Cuoco made a
point to check in on how he was doing
Ritter in response took her aside for a
moment and they had a conversation she
would never forget Cuoco explained how
he sat her down on the couch and told
her that he loves her to which she
responded in the same way he goes no I
want you know I love you
I said I love you too he goes that's it
and he gave me a hug and I was the last
I saw him his final interaction with
Cuoco is extremely telling of his
exceptionally caring Nature by
protecting the ones he truly loved and
letting them know how much he cared this
lasting image is fitting of the
endearing actor who inhabited the best
traits of fatherhood on eight simple
rules as the years have gone on Kaley
Cuoco has made it abundantly clear that
the memory of Ritter hasn't disappeared
from her mind 18 years after his death
she spoke with USA Today about who he
was as a person as well as a co-star she
mentioned a specific incident that took
place at their first table read of eight
simple rules she said in comes John and
I go hi I'm playing your daughter he
goes hold on and he takes his jacket and
puts it over me he goes never dress like
that again and right then he was my dad
Cuoco notes that he treated all of his
on-screen children as his own which made
it especially difficult to process his
death
speaking of the day of Ritter's passing
she said I just heard screaming and I
looked over and I see all these people
and everyone is just hysterical
according to her recollection of the day
Ritter passed everyone from actor Henry
Winkler to the Warner Brothers mailman
took it hard and felt devastated by the
event Winkler added it was so sudden so
shocking so sad September 11 2023 marks
20 years since John Ritter's Unexpected
death yet thanks to his impact on pop
culture as well as Kaley Cuoco the eight
simple rules staple has yet to fade from
the public consciousness